la presidenta Dina boluarte ha instalado
un gabinete de crisis y está evaluando
instalar un estado de emergencia
nacional en todo el Perú Por lo pronto a
la mandataria peruana ha declarado en
emergencia por 60 días calendarios a los
departamentos de ica y Arequipa y
también está disponiendo la ejecución de
la misma medida en la red Vial nacional
y para estos ha dispuesto que las
fuerzas armadas brinden protección a
puntos estratégicos del país Dina
bolivarle lo que quiere hacer es
restablecer la paz social protegiendo
los derechos humanos de los
manifestantes y que a su vez los
peruanos obtengan nuevamente el libre
tránsito hay que señalar que el
Ministerio el ministro de economía de
este país Alex Contreras ha revelado que
los disturbios están impactando
negativamente en la economía peruana él
ha dicho que por cada día de protestas
Perú pierde más de 26 millones de
dólares Francisco pero es que además la
fiscalía Pide a la corte 18 meses de
prisión o preventiva contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo que más
sigue en este proceso
en las próximas horas un tribunal va a
realizar una audiencia en la que
evaluará el pedido de prisión preventiva
de la fiscalía esto quiere decir que la
detención preliminar del expresidente
Pedro Castillo que vencía hoy a las 13
horas Lima Bogotá se va a extender hasta
que la corte
de un fallo resolutorio y
el el la defensa del ex gobernante va a
dar una dura batalla legal para tratar
de bloquear el pedido de 18 meses de
prisión preventiva de la fiscalía Pedro
Castillo ha hecho un llamado en una
carta a su simpatizantes para que lo
acompañen a la base de la policía porque
según Castillo hoy sí o sí saldría en
libertad